[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux on commence par la nouvelle qui
défraye la chronique en ce moment
préhistoriques planète le documentaire
sur les dinosaures sur apple tv plus
c'est en collaboration avec la bbc j'en
ai déjà parlé dans deux autres vidéos
donc je vais pas en reparler ici c'est
un documentaire que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié si vous voulez en savoir plus
sur mon avis sur ce documentaire je vous
invite à aller voir les deux autres
vidéos je mettrai les liens dans l'est
dans la description de cette vidéo donc
on va commencer directement par cette
annonce tonitruante qui a fait trembler
le petit monde de la paléontologie
est-ce que homo floresiensis vivrait
encore ono florensis le petit hominidés
qui a été retrouvé dans les îles
d'indonésie ville de flores ce petit
hominidés qu'on surnomme le hobbit
aurait-il encore vivant dans les forêts
d'indonésie
une annonce qui a été qui a été fait
dans un livre publié par
l'anthropologue grégory forte donc
anthropologue retraité de l'université
d'alberta au canada annonce qui est basé
nous dit cet article sur le recueil de
30 témoignages de gens qui ont vu une
créature similaire à l'homme de florès
et qui distille donc ressembler à homo
floresiensis enfin du moins
correspondent à la description qu'on
pourrait faire d'un homo floresiensis 30
témoignages de témoins visuels aurait vu
homo floresiensis
n'y aurait-il pas une discipline qui au
raid qui porterait déjà un nom et qui se
baserait très fortement sur des preuves
très faible comme les témoignages ne
sommes ne s'agirait-il pas d'un exemple
flagrant de cryptozoologie
eh bien oui vous l'aurez deviné c'est de
la cryptozoologie et la cryptozoologie
n'est pas une science mais bel et bien
une pseudo science j'ai passé une heure
34 dans cette vidéo a expliqué pourquoi
donc je vais pas recommencer maintenant
mais sachez que la cryptozoologie
est une science n'est pas une science
c'est une discipline pseudo scientifique
et que donc ce que nous fait ce que nous
fait le professeur forte ici c'est de la
pseudo-science donc ne vous inquiétez
pas non l'homme de flores ne survit pas
dans les jungles d'indonésie en tout cas
c'est pas 30 témoignage ou un bouquin
entier de cryptozoologie qui va vous
prouver le contraire on continue avec
les bestioles intelligente on lâche les
hominidés on rentre chez les dinosaures
avec les troodontidés vous connaissez
vous connaissez certainement la théorie
des troodontidés intelligent développé
par russell dans les années 70 donc
russell avait proposé que les trous dont
il était capable de faire des outils et
bien il y à une équipe de chercheurs que
ça intéressait comme hypothèse est
qu'ils ont essayé un peu de d'explorer
en fait cette voie dans une publication
dans le canadian journal of sound power
106 donc le journal canadien des
sciences de la terre et alors j'aime
beaucoup leur conclusion je pense que
méritent elles méritent d'être cités
étant donné les modifications faites sur
les outils par les archosaures moderne
donc les crocodiles et les oiseaux qui
utilisent parfois des outils ad le
plupart du temps à des fins rudimentaire
à je veux dire pour acquérir débusquer
de la nourriture à même les crocodiles
apparemment utilise utilisent des outils
et bien étant donné le peu de traces
qu'ils laissent sur les outils en
question il est quasiment impossible
donc là il parle d'un challenging
problème mais en réalité c'est un
euphémisme pour dire il est impossible
qu'on reconnaisse de tels faux cils
enfin qu'on reconnaisse de tels outils
dans le registre fossile c'est à dire
que quand bien même troodon utiliserait
utilisait pardon des outils à des fans
je sais pas quoi d'acquisition de
nourriture etc il n'y aurait aucun moyen
de le savoir
donc oui là par optimisation aussi les
crocodiles utilisent des outils de façon
rudimentaire et que les oiseaux certains
oiseaux utilisent aussi des outils de
façon rudimentaire il est probable que
les troodontidés les faits aussi mais
bon c'est pas le fait de juste agrippé
un bout de bois avec les dents avec les
avec les mains qui va laisser
suffisamment de traces sur un outil et
surtout des traces suffisamment
convaincante pour qu'on puisse dire est
ça c'est un outil de trop dont ce qui
fait de la théorie du trot dont qui
cherche qui utilisent pardon des outils
une théorie dompter stable et donc non
scientifique on reste dans le domaine
finalement de la pseudo-science menace
la transition avec le thème précédent on
reste dans une dans le pseudo
scientifique donc ça enterre plus ou
moins la théorie finalement du trot dont
utilisateurs d'outils
ceci étant dit les troodontidés sont
connus quand même pour avoir des
cerveaux relativement gros donc ça ça
change pas mais relativement gros par
rapport aux autres dinosaures un pas par
rapport aux oiseaux modernes
certainement pas par rapport aux oiseaux
modernes troodontidés ils sont dans la
dans la variation inférieur parmi les
oiseaux les plus stupides niveau taille
de cerveau donc mais au moins on pourra
pas dire que ça n'intéresse pas les
scientifiques et si ça vous intéresse
vous bah du coup vous pourrez voir
maintenant qu'il y a de la littérature
voilà sur les les dinosaures ont-ils pu
développer une culture de l'outil la
réponse et si oui on ne saura jamais
voilà
on reste avec les dinosaures et on va
parler maintenant des pays brady t-rex
dix petits bras du t-rex les sujets qui
fâchent
voici un nouvel article publié par pas
diane donc paléontologues assez connu
dans acta palaeontologica polonica qui
est une revue de paléontologie
complètement gratuite polonaise donc
c'est un article qui est très facile à
trouver bon de toute façon comme
d'habitude je vous mettrais un lien dans
la description pour télécharger tous les
articles ça change pas donc qui
interroge donc pourquoi les
tyrannosaures avait des petits bras
voilà une hypothèse intégrative alors
intégratif je suis pas sûr de comment
traduire ça mais en gros l'idée c'est
que
au lieu d'aller chercher des fonctions
pour des bras qui à l'évidence ne
servait à rien
pourquoi et si la fonction de ses bras
étaient n'était justement pas de servir
à rien un point d'interrogation
je reformule s'il est plutôt que d'aller
chercher un usage pour ses bras pour ces
tout petits bras à tyrannosaurus
d'inventer une force herculéenne à ses
petits bras riquiqui quoi qu'ils en ont
en plus tyrannosaure n'avait pas besoin
je veux dire regardez un rapace les
rapaces utilisent leurs ailes pour voler
mais je veux dire ça leur empêche pas
d'attraper leur proie avec leur bec avec
leur sert tyrannosaure c'est pareil avec
sa bouche absolument gigantesque et
cédant absolument énorme et ses griffes
des pâtes absolument gigantesque est
énorme et la puissance de ses membres il
avait pas besoin de bras tyrannosaurus
n'avait pas besoin de bras donc donc le
e ce qui pose enfin pas d'y ans lorsque
la question que pose pas bien c'est et
si en fait on se serait pas gouré est-ce
que la fonction des bras de t-rex basse
aurait pas était d'être petit justement
est-ce qu'être petit n'était pas une fin
en soi voilà au niveau des petits bras
de t-rex à ce que au final t-rex on sait
enfin pas t-rex mêlée tyrannosauridés de
manière générale qui avaient tous des
petits bras de toute façon les
tyrannosauridés de manière générale on
sait grâce à des centaines de fossiles
des centaines de mandibules de
maxillaire et crâne on sait grâce à des
centaines de fossiles que il communiquer
énormément en se mordant les uns et les
autres en se mordant la face les uns les
autres en se mordant en général les uns
les autres
donc en partant de ce principe là avoir
des gros brave avoir des gros bras c'est
quand même avoir des cibles privilégiées
du web pendant ces morsures parce
qu'évidemment c'est de la morsure
sociale certes mais c'est pas de la
morsure pauli 1 je vais dire ils sont
pas sympas les uns avec les autres quand
ils se mordent c'était des gros
chasseurs ils avaient besoin d'immenses
territoires dont qu'il communiquait à la
platé chez moi craqué je te bouffent le
nez quoi
il y avait de la morsure social
probablement aussi au niveau des des
moments de reproduction peut-être qu'il
se mordait justement pendant ces moments
de reproduction c'est pendant ces
parades nuptiales donc tout ça ça tout
ça ça laisse des blessures importantes
et notamment quand vous avez déjà des
petits bras de base parce que les
théropodes il avait déjà des petits
relativement petit bras de base à l'est
il suffit d'attraper un de ses petits
bras avec ses grosses dans la et puis
vous finissez vite avec une carrosserie
de coupé et une hémorragie qui va finir
par vous tuer ou un bras qui va finir
par s'est infectée et c'est en fait ces
braves vous imaginez bien que quand que
ses bras c'était des cibles privilégiées
et donc ce qu'il propose dans cet
article c'est une nouvelle hypothèse qui
disent les bras en fait d'eux des
tyrannosauridés sont devenus petit pour
éviter justement d'être blessé enfin il
y aura il ya eu une sélection naturelle
extrêmement fortes contre des bras trop
grande on trop facile à attraper et a
blessé et du coup à
deux avec les bras trop grand ce serait
une trop grande chance de finir avec une
hémorragie ou une affection donc la
fonction de ses petits bras c'était
d'être petit et de servir à rien voilà
et moi je les aime bien cette hypothèse
mais je les aime bien je trouve qu'elle
a du cachet plutôt que de chercher à
dire plutôt d'imaginer que le tir et que
ça a aidé le t-rex à se relever quand il
était allongé si je dire aucun oiseau
notre problème à se relever
même les plus gros jeux le dire même les
autruches aucun plutôt que de dire que
ça servait à accrocher les femelles
pendant la reproduction que rien non
plus je dire attirer qu'il a déjà une
bouche énorme s'il avait besoin
d'attraper la femelle pendant la
reproduction il l'aurait attrapé avec
ses dents quoi donc il aurait fait comme
les lions je veux dire c'est les lions
qui font ça ils attrapent les femelles
par le par le parent le coup pendant
l'accouplement donc je dirais il a déjà
un énorme outils pour attraper la
femelle en la personne de sa bouche donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils iraient à
invoquer les tout petits bras non il n'y
a pas de raison la bonne raison là je
pense qu'on a vraiment une très bonne
raison pour laquelle t-rex avait des
petits bras enfin des tyrannosauridés
avait des petits bras bah c'est parce
que c'est parce que d'une salle leur
servait pas à grand chose et que de deux
il y avait en plus une pression
sélective une sélection naturelle contre
la présence de petits bras très fort à
faire contre la présence de bras tout
court très fort parce que ses bras il
était dans le passage à chaque fois
qu'ils essayaient de se mordre les uns
les autres pour communiquer ce dont ceux
dont on a de beaucoup de preuves on a
des centaines de preuves de sa qui se
mordait pour communiquer donc moi je
trouve que c'est un article très
intéressant et je vous invite à le lire
si vous souhaitez en savoir plus on
reste chez les dinosaures mais on se
déplace cette fois chez les herbivores
avec un nouveau petit oeuf qui a été
décrit en chine un petit top dalle rose
or regardez ils ont fait une
reconstruction c'est trop mignon vous
rappelez l'ovi raptor la cac qui a fait
tellement de vue et celui-là il est
complètement passée en deux sous le
radar ça tout de fou pour salades rose
or en même temps c'est pas comme si le
dire depuis maya saura on en a découvert
des oeillades rose or mais là c'est
quand même un cadre aux orres qui est
dans son oeuf et cet oeuf et bien c'est
un oeuf de tips feroli tus ses écrits je
crois dans le titre c'est pas écrit dans
le titre c'est écrit dans le résumé de
ce fait roll it idée donc c'est un oeuf
de type pis feroli d'idées et alors
c'est super intéressant parce que en
france on a trouvé plein de spero lis tu
sais il me semble que c'est à rennes le
château notamment quand elle a trouvé
pas mal et du coup maintenant qu'on a
d'un petit embryon à l'intérieur ça
démontre définitivement que c'est aux
féroé les hits us enfin les sphères au
liquide est ce que c'est ce pardon paseo
que c'est eux
qu'on a découvert un bond à mort en
france appartiennent bien à des adrs or
parce qu'ils avaient quand même un doute
parce qu'évidemment les adh rose or ils
sont pas très commun dans le registre
fossile français on n'en trouve pas tant
que ça mais on sait que sur la fin du
crétacé il commençait à arriver en
europe il commençait à remplacer
notamment les herbivores locaux que sont
les les ans peloso russes par exemple en
peloso russe donc sauropodes
titanosaures idées et leurs abdos don
qui est un petit ornitho pod et en plus
là je veux dire il ya pas de doute sur
l'identification regarder on voit les
dents c'est définitivement de la petite
dans de petites dents en batterie de
dan rose or quoi donc là c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment très mignon c'est un très
joli petit fossiles c'est dommage qu'il
soit passé à ce point sous la barre
parce que vraiment il méritait un peu
plus d'attention et en plus ça
directement des implications sur
l'identification de nos yeux à nous en
france donc c'est quand même cool on
sort des dinosaures pour aller du côté
des de leurs cousins archosaures rien
les ptérosaures avec maintenant donc une
nouvelle découverte de ptérosaure à
plumes ou que voici que voilà donc là
vous avez l'arrière d'un crâne de
ptérosaure ici
et donc il y aurait des petites plumes
dans ce coin là voilà donc notamment ici
vous voyez
je vous le gros si des plumes très
filamenteuses et des plumes ici un petit
peu un petit peu en peigne voilà donc ça
trouvait sur un crâne de ptérosaure de
qui s'appelle tente en dupant dactyle us
tupan d'actus
qui nous vient du crétacé inférieur de
brésil donc déjà ça c'est une preuve de
plus que les s'il en fallait que les
ptérosaures avait effectivement donc des
structures proches des plumes voilà le
fossile en entier donc il ya une espèce
d'énorme crête ici et donc les plus
belles sont elles sont à l'arrière je
crois donc là voilà c'est l'énorme crête
que vous voyez là et les plumes se
trouve à l'arrière donc cette crête là
et les plumes elle se trouve là le long
de l'os donc les petites plumes pectine
et là elle se trouve en haut en bleu et
les petites plumes filamenteuses se
trouve en bas
et donc ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec
ce tube en d'acti l'usba c'est que ces
petites plumes elles sont situées à un
endroit qui sont pas je veux dire il n'y
a pas besoin de se réchauffer
spécialement à cet endroit là c'est pas
des plumes qui servent au vol évidemment
c'est des plumes qui sont situés sur
l'organe l'organe qui on le suppose
devait servir d'organe sexuelle quoi il
devait servir à séduire les femelles et
a impressionné les mâles rivaux cette
espèce de grande crête sur la tête est
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant du coup c'est
de constater qu'en plus il ya des petits
mélanosomes à l'intérieur de ces plumes
donc c'est plus mais elles étaient
colorées ses plumes elle était colorée
et donc vous avez des plumes colorées
sur un organe reproducteur bon bah ça
veut dire que c'est un soutien très
fortement l'hypothèse que vous voyez là
ils ont représenté avec deux couleurs
différentes ça soutient très fortement
l'hypothèse que les plumes à la base en
tout cas les plumes très simple de ce
genre là ont pu évoluer dans un rôle de
communication sexuelle et notamment pour
la parade nuptiale évidemment et pas
seulement pour se réchauffer pas
seulement pour l'an ii termine donc
c'est ce qu'il propose dans cet article
et en plus de proposer cette hypothèse
que de l'évolution de l'origine pour la
sélection sexuelle des plumes il propose
aussi évidemment mais ça ça avait déjà
été proposée avant que l'ancêtre en
commun alors des dinosaures donc lancer
trop commun des dinosaures ici de ce
côté là voici l'arbre phylogénétique de
ce côté-ci tous à lasser les dinosaures
donc l'ancêtre en commun des dinosaures
et des ptérosaures que vous voyez là
donc voici les ptérosaures de ce côté-ci
deux groupes chez qui on a découvert des
plumes et bien que cet ancêtre en commun
celui de tous les avais métatarse alia
possédait déjà des petites plumes
relativement simple filamenteuses
filamenteuses ou légèrement pectiné mais
qu'il possédait déjà des plumes et ce1
et ce malgré le fait que il ya plein de
dinosaures parce qu'on me le rappelle à
chaque fois il ya plein de dinosaures
qui n'ont effectivement pas de plumes
tyrannosaurus ici à lauzon russe car nos
torts
les sauropodes les iguanes donc laissé
rate obtient sauf psittacosaurus
là on a deux coups linda drôme et us à
la base de l'arbre ici qui a des plumes
aussi donc qui a déplu mais après on a
des tirés au sort parmi les anti siens
qui n'ont pas de plus en plus donc ça
c'est en fait c'est une méthode de
reconstruction ce qui ce qui nous dit en
fait que les lancers être en commun
avaient des plumes c'est pas le fossile
lui-même de deux tubes en d'acti lui ça
c'est la méthode de reconstruction des
caractères ancestraux qui est utilisé
dans cet arbre donc qui est une méthode
par maximum vous voyez ici c maximum de
vraisemblance voilà donc ils ont utilisé
un algorithme de maximum de
vraisemblance pour reconstituer les
caractères ancestraux à partir de ce
qu'on sait de la présence ou non de
plumes chez les ch et les dîners chez
les dinosaures qu'on connaît pour
lesquelles on a des morceaux de
fragments au moins des fragments de peau
préserver
donc à partir de ça ils reconstituent
que la condition ancestrales et donc la
condition ancestrale reconstitué pour
les dinosaures pour les ptérosaures et
pour les lans être en commun des deux en
général c'est très forte probabilité de
présence de plumes essentiellement mono
filamenteuses vous voyez que c'est le
rose qui domine ici ici ici
donc très fortes chances de plus mono
filamenteuses et avec alors pour les
avait même des tatars seul lien on a
aussi des petites plumes en touche et on
a des petites plumes en brosse aussi
qu'ils sont possibles alors faut voir
que c'est des probabilités un cd procéda
vraisemblance donc ce qu'on a lassé des
probabilités c'est pas des vérités
absolues évidemment mais ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est quand même de noter
que la reconstruction ne place jamais
l'absence de plumes comme étant un
caractère ancestral ceci étant dit là où
c'est intéressant c'est quand on va
explorer les les informations
supplémentaires donc où on y trouve des
analyses supplémentaires des plumes et
notamment d'autres scénarios pour
essayer d'expliquer la transformation de
ces plumes ancestrale en plumes plus
évoluée des plumes plus proche de celle
des oiseaux
est en fait dans cette danse et
matériels supplémentaires on découvre
l'existence de trois autres analyses
qu'ils n'ont pas retenu pour l'article
principal l'article principal il
s'arrête là donc là je descends je des
singes des singes des saints anges
descendent et j'arrive à ces trois
analyses et donc sur ces trois analyses
y en a qu'une seule qui retrouve les
plumes comme caractère ancestral des
dinosaures et des oiseaux les deux
autres voiliers c'est noir est tout noir
c'est les écailles tout noir c'est les
écailles donc les plumes sont
reconstruites en c'est strahl pour les
oiseaux pour les ptérosaures pardon mais
par contre c'est ancestrale complètement
le caractère ancestral pour les
dinosaures c'est les cailles et dans cet
autre analyse là en dessous encore une
fois les dinosaures le conditions
ancestrale c'est les cayes alors
pourquoi il nous parle pas de celle là
bas c'est tout simplement parce qu'il y
en a des méthodes de mesures qui
permettent enfin qui permettent de juger
de la qualité d'un modèle puisque là ce
qu'on vous montre là c'est juste un
modèle c'est juste des probabilités hein
c'est juste un scénario purement
hypothétique basé sur des calculs de
probabilités donc la raison pour
laquelle ils n'ont pas sélectionné les
deux autres modèles c'est parce que les
deux autres modèles renvoyer des valeurs
de probables des valeurs de
vraisemblance en l'occurrence puisqu'ils
l'ont utilisé simone de référence est
renvoyé des valeurs de vraisemblance
moins intéressante - moins bonne on a
des façons de comparer comme ça des
modèles phylogénétique pour essayer d'en
tirer les meilleurs ce qui donne le
meilleur signal hélas celui qui donnait
le meilleur signal c'est celui qui place
la plume comme ancestrales et pas les
cailles du coup mais des plumes
relativement simple quand même mine de
rien ce qui n'exclut pas qu'il y avait
aussi des écailles un d'ailleurs comme
encore une fois c'est juste une
probabilité
mais en tout cas c'est super intéressant
de voir qu'il ya voyez ça se remet
encore en question à chaque fois le
l'ancestralité de la plume mais il
semblerait bien que les scénarios
convergent vers une solution où les
plumes en tout cas les mono filament
donc les plus mule les protoplumes comme
on les appelle des fois
serait la condition ancestrale la plus
probable chez nos amis les dinosaures on
reste au temps des dinosaures avec un
nouvel article qui est un peu un peu
comme celui sur troodon assez un article
qui est accessible en il est accessible
en pré print enfin c'est pas un pré
print mais c'est la version manuscrite
mais c'est la version manuscrite telle
qu'elle a été publiée c'est juste que
elle est accessible sur internet en
version manuscrite est pas en version
mise en page quoi c'est tout donc ça
manque de mise en page voilà mais ça
veut pas dire que c'est pas ça n'a pas
été revue par les pairs comme n'importe
quel article donc ça a été revu ça a été
publiée dans la revue prestigieuse celle
et donc c'est un article qui remet en
question la co évolution entre les
plantes à fleurs des angiospermes et les
insectes pollinisateurs sur la base
d'une grande revue de la littérature
dont ils ont vraiment épluché toute la
littérature sur le sujet jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on est en 2022 mais 2022 et
ils ont ils ont donc conclu que les
plantes à fleurs ont pas vraiment l'air
d'avoir évolué en même temps ou sous
l'affluence ou avec ou sans les insectes
enfin sans si justement sans les
insectes pollinisateurs
donc là on n'est pas là on est donc
paléozoïque donc carbonifère père bien
mésozoïque trias jurassique crétacé
cénozoïque paléo néogène donc
l'extinction des dinosaures elle est là
la entre ce bleu clair et ce bleu un peu
plus foncée enfin moi je les vois un
bleu mais après vous faites ce que vous
voulez et là on a ses petits poings avec
des marges d'erreur au tour s'il s'agit
pas d'un de toute la distribution du
groupe il s'agit juste de la marge
d'erreur dont il y en a certains qui ont
des marges d'erreur assez colossal mais
en gros le petit point c'est l'origine
d'un groupe particulier de
pollinisateurs ou d'enjeu sperme donc là
vous avez les angiospermes ici vous avez
le trait qui est la découverte d'un
pollen qui appartient définitivement à
un enjeu sperme et le reste c'est des
points qui correspond à tous les
possibles insectes pollinisateurs donc
les papillons les abeilles les autres
hyménoptères ici il ya des coléoptères
il ya des ya d'autres d'autres papillon
ici mais qui sont pas apparemment avec
des trompe les tisanes aubeterre et les
diptères donc les bouches qui
pollinisent aussi un petit peu et donc
là on regarde le registre fossile de
tout ce beau monde et on constate que la
plupart des pollinisateurs sont apparus
soit au permien avec encore une fois une
marge d'erreur mais en gros ils sont
soit apparue au permien soit ils sont
apparus au crétacé et pas dans la
première moitié du crétacé mais plutôt
la deuxième moitié du crétacé alors que
les angiospermes elles sont apparus
quelque part entre le début du crétacé
et le début du trias donc en fait on a
découplage total entre le l'origine des
entre la possible origine des
pollinisateurs et la possible origine
des angiospermes c'est à dire que même
en prenant même en prenant des grosses
marges d'erreurs ça on voit pas du tout
une co évolution en fait entre les deux
on voit même registre fossile qui
s'opposent diamétralement avec une
origine d'un côté des angiospermes
pendant le mésozoïque la moitié
inférieure du mésozoïque alors même que
pendant ce temps là on now paléozoïque
alors que les pollinisateurs les plus
communs que sont les abeilles et les
papillons baheux
ils trouvent leur origine qu au crétacé
donc leur origine au crétacé et
certainement une conséquence
à long terme de l'apparition des
angiospermes au jurassique et au début
du crétacé ça ils veulent bien
l'admettre
mais mais bon ça n'empêche que on
s'attendrait quand même à ce que la
révolution high un peu plus ce magma
dans la main et soit pas 150 enfin 50
millions d'années près si vous voyez
l'idée parce que là c'est quand même 50
millions d'années la spa de temps là
donc on s'attendrait quand même à un peu
mieux entre deux groupes qui sont censés
évoluer ensemble on s'attendrait à une
meilleure synchronicité qu'à 50 millions
d'années près quoi même sachant
même sachant le temps long que prend
l'évolution surtout c'est chez les
invertébrés de petite taille on s'attend
quand même à ce que ça aille plus vite
que ça donc il essaie de proposer des
explications une des explications c'est
évidemment là pollination chez les
gymnastes berne c'est à dire que la
plupart des il ya beaucoup d'insectes
pollinisateurs qui était déjà des
pollinisateurs de gymnospermes et du
coup les enjeux sperme serait apparu de
leur côté sans avoir spécialement besoin
d'une pollinisation par les insectes et
ensuite aurait remplacé les gymnospermes
dans ce rôle là
quand les gymnospermes aurait commencé à
péricliter
camp ou à cause ou parce que c'est
évidemment c'est pas facile de savoir
qui de l'oeuf ou de la poule a eu lieu
le premier donc on a c'est juste qu'on a
ce découplage et je trouve ça super
intéressant parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une histoire qu'on lui dit tout le
temps et les abeilles qui ont co évolué
avec les plantes et avec les plantes à
fleurs etc oui à partir du milieu du
crétacé mais alors avant ça c'est pas
dit en fait que en gros ce que ça remet
en question c'est que le succès des
angiospermes est due à la pollinisation
des insectes ou que le succès des
insectes pollinisateurs est due à la
présence dans le jeu sperme en fait il
est probable qu'il ait commencé à bosser
ensemble bien plus bien plus tard voilà
eux ils proposent même que la co
évolution réelle n'a réellement commencé
qu'au paléogène et qu'avant ça on avait
on avait de plus tôt de l'opportunisme
quoi donc c'est vraiment intéressant
comme article je vous suggère de le lire
parce qu'il ya plein de
plein de bonnes idées dedans il ya plein
d'hypothèses faut voir qu'une relation
symbiotique comme celle là c'est
évidemment faux pas voir ça tellement
comme une symbiose que comme un co
parasitisme en fait ce qui évidemment
les quand tu viens quand tu viens boire
le nectar tu bois le produit de la
plante a produit justement avec avec
grand peine parce que ce nectar il est
sucré et se sucrent il sort pas de nulle
part il sort de la photosynthèse donc ça
prend de l'énergie ça prend des
ressources de le fabriquer ce nectar
donc évidemment la plante veux pas faire
ça sans contrepartie 1 c'est pas la
plante qui dit gentiment à la bei et y
apprendront ha tu veux bien prendre mes
petits pollen avec senna tient à prendre
mon pollen dans ta gueule
espèce de voleuse de nectar
sert à quelque chose fais quelque chose
de ta vie quoi merde
poste de gland 2 d'abeilles et donc
et de l'autre côté il ya la bei
effectivement qui essayent de profiter
du nectar il ya les abeilles pendant que
ça mais ça se voit très bien avec les
papillons c'est les papillons qui ont
des très grandes trompe et qui du coup
essaye de boire le nectar sans toucher
la plante
surtout en évitant de foot les pieds
dans la plante du mois dans tal al
longues trompes qui leur permet d'aller
succès le nectar mais surtout pas non je
veux pas toucher ton plein de la mer dit
mahut
ça qu'on a décollé évolution assez assez
grotesque du coup avec des plantes qui
deviennent super profondes et des et des
papillons qui finissent par avoir une
super longue trop en fait c'est pas
c'est pas tant une conque évolution
qu'une course aux armements en fait
c'est une course à celui qui en prendra
le plus à l'autre c'est ça c'est cette
symbiose en fait c'est celui qui en
prendra le plus à l'autre en en donnant
le moins faut pas voir les symbioses
comme comme des relations sympa c'est
pas du tout une relation sympathique
unsa bio c'est une relation où il y en a
deux qui essayent de bouffer se bouffer
la l'autre mais il se bouche à la même
vitesse en fait du coup il serait
général abel vitesse aussi quoi bref on
reste avec les invertébrés et maintenant
on passe aux arthropodes les trilobites
les fameux trilobites du paléozoïque en
apprenant le mot trilobites un jour en
l'entendant pour la première fois vous
vous êtes forcément demander mais est-ce
que les trilobites ça a quelque chose à
voir avec leur
avec avec ça et du coup et si oui la
question est est-ce que s'ils en ont 3
del hobbit ou est ce qu'ils en ont plus
mais ce qui sera un non moins et bien la
réponse on l'a maintenant ils en ont pas
trois ils en ont 4 les trilobites en
avait 4 je tiens désormais le titre de
cette vidéo les trilobites en ont 4
alors commencer et bien grâce aux
schistes de burgess bien sûr les
schistes de burgès qui préserve des
trilobites on a tendance à oublier d'en
parler parce qu'il ya tellement de trucs
zarbi ou schistes de burgess mais il ya
aussi des trilobites parmi les plus
anciens d'ailleurs qu'on connaisse et en
analysant ces trilobites eh ben ils ont
deux les gens ont découvert alors les
chercheurs du canada des chercheurs de
renom pardon des chercheurs de cambridge
massachussetts l'ossau et ortega
hernandez ont découvert que les
trilobites en fait il avait des petites
pattes réduite sur le côté l'arrière de
leur corps voyez ces matelas qui sont
représentés en couleur là ici est alors
ses petites pattes réduite eh bien ils
ont fait l'hypothèse qu'il s'agissait de
classe père c'est-à-dire de petites
pattes comme on trouve chez les
arthropodes moderne des petites pattes
comme chez notamment comme chez velits
mule qui servent à attraper la femelle
au niveau justement des organes génitaux
pour bien retenir et pour être bien sûr
de pouvoir la féconder comme il faut
donc ils avaient deux paires de pattes
sexuels dont 4 donc alors ils n'avaient
pas 4 bits il avait quatre classes père
et c'est que la sptr donc ce qu'il
propose dans cet article c'est que les
classes père en fait servait quand le
mal monté la femelle en fait servaient à
attraper la femelle ici là juste à
l'arrière du corps et on attrape or la
femelle à l'arrière du corps comme ça en
fait ils la tiennent bien juste à
l'endroit où ils pondent sait où elle
pour ses oeufs et du coup ça permet
d'arroser les oeufs donc c'était une
fécondation externe donc il ya
définitivement pas de bitche et les
trilobites voilà c'est une fécondation
externe et donc ils attrapent la femelle
arrosent les oeufs et du coup ils sont
bien les oeufs sont bien recouvert par
le corps du mal et le mal est bien
située juste au niveau de l'arrière de
la femelle soutenu par ses classes père
comme ça il est sûr d'envoyer la purée
où il faut
voilà vous n'avez jamais jamais voulu en
savoir autant sur la vie sexuelle des
trilobites et ben maintenant tu sais
quand même voilà
donc les donc cet article répond
effectivement à la question les
trilobites bas n'avaient pas de beats on
a fini de parler de bide parlant de
cerveau les cerveaux justement est bien
le lait on avait cette impression il ya
de cela quelques mois encore que les
mammifères à partir du début du
cénozoïque en fait le cerveau des
mammifères n'avait fait que grandir en
moyenne on va dire en moyenne les
mammifères ont commencé leur évolution
ces deux olic avec un tout petit cerveau
et puis chaque ligne et de mammifères
indépendamment a
évolué dans la direction d'un cerveau
plus gros avec certains cas extrêmes
comme homo sapiens mais aussi d'autres
cas d'autres cas moins extrêmes comme
les chevaux par exemple
les éléphants un petit peu mieux mais
voilà avec globalement il n'y a pas
beaucoup de mammifères dont le cerveau
n'a pas évolué dans la direction d'un
plus gros cerveau et donc en moyenne et
il ya eu il ya quelques mammifères comme
certaines choses sourit chez qui le
cerveau est devenu plus petit en
comparaison du corps mais de manière
générale ça reste quand même une
évolution vers le plus gros cerveau et
alors il ya la chercheuse française
ornella bertrand alors française mais
pas forcément basée en france
puisqu'elle est à l'université
d'edimbourg en ce moment et bien sept
chercheurs française a étudié quelques
mammifères du paléocène donc les tout
premiers mammifères
qui avait été justement découvert tout
récemment je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez cette étude qui avait proposé
qui avait montré en fait que les
mammifères tout de suite après la limite
crétacé tertiaire les mammifères avec
tout de suite après commencé à grossir
en taille en fait et donc elle a pris
ces mammifères là elle les a scanné
enfin ou du moins c'est elle et ses
collègues les ont scanné et ils ont
étudié le cerveau pour voir en fait si
le cerveau suivait la même tendance
c'est à dire est ce qu en plus de
l'augmentation de la taille du corps est
ce qu'on avait une augmentation de la
taille du cerveau
alors dans son échantillonnage il ya par
exemple ces trois cerveaux là celui de
arctos sion en raw qui est un maisonny
kid et celui de troc aux us qui est un
stylo dont tu donc je crois que c'est
des herbivores les tyloo dante et ira q
ce qui est donc un périssol dactyle
proche des chevaux et des rhinocéros
alors déjà j'attire votre attention sur
la toute petite taille du néocortex le
néocortex les tout petits chez ces bêtes
là c'est assez fou il ya même il y avait
un autre qui s'appelle et etc etc tonus
je crois ou le cortex le néocortex c'est
tellement petit que quand vous regardez
le cerveau du dessous on dirait deux
petits patches sur le sommet du cerveau
donc tout le reste basse et du palais au
cortex par définition qui accomplit des
fonctions un peu plus basiques donc on
va passer pas un cours de neurologie
évidemment mais voilà c'est juste l'idée
c'est ça c'est que voyez déjà ils ont un
tout petit néocortex malheur en plus
quand elle a mesuré la taille du cerveau
ce qu'elle a trouvé d'intéressant en
fête et notamment en mesurant ce qu'on
appelle le quotient dans ses valises à
sion c'est à dire la taille du cerveau
par rapport au corps pour faire simple
parce que j'ai pas envie de réexpliquer
j'ai fait toute une vidéo sur
l'évolution du cerveau des homininés
vous pouvez aller la voir si jamais ça
vous intéresse laissez moi un
commentaire et je vous copie ray je vous
coller le lien vers cette vidéo sur
l'évolution du cerveau des homininés où
j'explique en détail ce que c'est que le
quotient à ses fans isation mais là pour
cette vidéo là on va juste partir du
principe que le quotient l'encéphale
isation c'est une mesure de la taille du
cerveau sur la taille du corps ce qui
évidemment la taille absolue du cerveau
ne veut rien dire du tout une souris et
plus intelligente qu un varan de komodo
qui a pourtant un cerveau plus gros en
taille absolue mais évidemment la souris
la souris est un cerveau plus gros par
rapport à la taille de son corps donc ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on me jure le
quotient dans ses valises à sion la
taille relative du cerveau par rapport
au corps est-ce qu'on voit est ce qui
est assez fabuleux c'est que bat donc le
cerveau des mammifères du mésozoïque et
plus ancefa lisez que celui de ces
mammifères la du paléocène et c à c ur
et après seulement on a une tendance à
l'augmentation de la taille du cerveau à
l'eocène au début de l'éocène et à la
fin de l'éocène
donc c'est seulement après que la taille
du cerveau augmente méreau paléocène les
mammifères ont un cerveau plus petit que
leurs ancêtres du mésozoïque don kikas
en fait cette
casse en fait cette tendance évolutive
qu'on croyait avoir vu sur l'évolution
du cerveau est en fait là sur
l'évolution du cerveau qui ne faisait
que devenir plus gros et ce qu'ils ont
montré donc eh bah c'est que en fait
voyez là ça c'est le quotient dans ses
valises à sion en fonction des millions
d'années ici on à la limite crétacé
paléogène ou crétacé-tertiaire le
cerveau augmente de cerveau augmenté à
la crise braille se pète la gueule et ré
augmente de façon drastique tout de
suite après et donc bon bah déjà il ya
un effet de la crise mais surtout il ya
un effet de l'évolution de la taille
regarder ça c'est l'évolution de la body
mass donc c'est l'évolution de la taille
à regarder pareil on approche de la
crise la taille se pète un peu la gueule
mais alors pendant la crise et alors que
les dinosaures sont en train de
s'éteindre les mammifères enfin la
taille elle repart de plus belle elle
part vers le haut beaucoup plus vite que
la taille de cerveau est en fait c'est
ça qui se produit c'est qu'en fait la
taille du corps augmente plus vite
beaucoup plus vite que la taille du
cerveau après la crise crétacé paléogène
chez les mammifères ce qui donne en fait
bassa donc le l'encéphale isation et
petit quand elle est foncée et haute
quand elle éclaire donc tous les trucs
moderne là que vous voyez en doute
branche là ils ont des cerveaux ils ont
des branches clair donc ils ont plutôt
des cerveaux gros et tous ceux à la
limite crétacé paléogène là ces petits
pointillés voyez qu'ils ont des branches
très très foncée et donc chaque branche
a ensuite évolué vers des un cerveau
plus gros mais indépendamment donc c'est
complètement de la convergence évolutive
en fait un gros cerveau n'était pas
n'est pas un caractère partagé par tous
les mammifères à la base le gros cerveau
c'est quelque chose qui a évolué après
donc ça c'est un très très bel article
qui est qui jette vraiment
une théorie qui a qui est beaucoup
représentée dans les dents les cours
dans les cours 2 d'évolution des
mammifères donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important de belles
découvertes café on est là bertrand et
toute son équipe donc on les félicite et
on termine avec l'origine du dingo le
dago c'est pas le copain de mickey c'est
ceci dit c'est son inspiration c'est ce
chien australien donc sauvage chiens
sauvages australien dont on se demande
toujours est ce que c'est un chien
domestique qui a été relâché par les
premiers humains qui sont arrivées sur
les îles de sur les îles d'indonésie
alors pas forcément les plus tout
premier parce qu'il ya 5 ils sont
arrivés il ya cinquante mille ans et les
premiers humains n'avaient pas de chien
à 50 mille ans met donc les humains qui
sont arrivés un peu après du coup alors
s'agit-il d'un chien qui a été relâché
par les humains qui sont donc les
ancêtres des aborigènes d'australie ou
s'agit-il d'un chien qui vivaient déjà
là parce que ça en fonction de l'un ou
de l'autre c'est pas du tout les mêmes
efforts de conservation qui font déployé
six et les humains qui ont introduit
quand bien même ce sont les aborigènes
d'australie il ya très longtemps je veux
dire si c'est les humains qui ont
introduit le dago sur en australie c'est
une espèce invasive le dingo donc on va
pas le traité de la même façon et
surtout pas le protéger de la même façon
que s'il s'agissait d'une espèce de
chien qui vivaient déjà en australie
avant l'arrivée des humains donc c'est
très important de déterminer la position
phylogénétique du dingo ça a des
conséquences immédiates sur la sur les
efforts de conservation qui font
déployés pour garder ces dingos et du
coup cet article les bains est l'un des
premiers à proposer
du mois analyse génétique à l'appui
c'est l'un des premiers à proposer va
que le dingo voyez il est à la base là
c'est l'arbre phylogénétique il commence
en donnant les loups il comme il
continue en donnant les dingos et il
continue en donnant le reste des races
de chiens qu'on connaît et donc là ce
qu'on a c'est que du coup le dingo il
est très banal dans la phylogénie donc
ça veut dire qu'il est très proche
d'un loup et que donc la de l'événement
domestication en fête aurait pu avoir
lieu que ici dans l'arbre phylogénétique
et du coup le dingo ne serait pas un
chien domestique ce serait un chien
sauvage la grande force de cette étude
c'est qu'ils ont utilisés des génomes
entiers donc il beaucoup de données la
grande faiblesse de cette étude c'est
que pour obtenir des génomes entiers il
a fallu qu'ils réduisent leur
échantillonnage et en l'occurrence ils
ont réduit leur échantillonnage à
seulement 1 2 3 4 5 5 chiens et un look
ça ça réduit beaucoup la puissance de
leurs analyses on va dire et la deuxième
le deuxième truc à propos des dingos
c'est qu'ils ont fait il a fallu qu'il
reconstitue à génome est en fait de dago
parce que ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui
les génomes de dago pure ils ont été
trop hybride et donc il a fallu qu'il
reconstitue par croisement donc ils ont
fait un gros grande campagne de
croisement c'est certainement la raison
pour laquelle si publié dans une grande
revue scienza de 26 sur cus succursale
de 5 ans donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils ont publié dans cette
grande revue c'est qu'il a fallu qu'il
recrée de toutes pièces un dingo pure en
faisant des croisements et donc comment
évalue-t-on la pureté d'un ragot la
pureté de la race pour évoquer des gros
mots j'ai envie de dire pour pour sortir
des gros mots comment évalue-t-on cette
pureté cette pureté est telle et telle
est l objectivement pure envie de dire
est-elle représentative de ce qu'étaient
les dingos avant et surtout et bien
est-ce que c'est pertinent de comparer
ce à seulement six autres espèces enfin
six autres races en l'occurrence 6 autre
sous-espèce de loups devrais je les
appelais donc ça c'est une ça ce sont
des grosses faiblesses de cette étude
voilà jusqu'à quel point ce génome de
dago est représentative des dingos et
jusqu'à quel point 6 et sont six
échantillons sont représentatifs de la
diversité des races de chiens sachant
comme je le disais que ça va à
l'encontre d'à peu près tout ce qu'on
sait de l'évolution des chiens l'origine
des chiens ont toutes les analyses
précédentes la place dans alors au
moyen-orient en europe de l'est quelque
part par là toutes ces analyses place
l'origine des chiens là et place ensuite
la dispersion des dago en australie avec
l'être humain en compagnie est donc de
l'être humain quoi comme animal de
compagnie avec l'être humain
plusieurs milliers d'années après
l'origine des chiens elle-même et s'est
même pas dit d'ailleurs j'ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'ils étaient arrivés avec les
aborigènes d'australie mais en réalité
peut-être même pas fait même avec des
populations encore plus tardive donc je
corrige petit petit erratum sur ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça se trouve
c'est même pas avec les aborigènes
d'australie qui sont arrivés c'est
peut-être avec des populations encore
plus tardive et encore une fois ça
change toute l'histoire aussi bien ça
change toute cette histoire aussi c'est
à dire que avec qui sont arrivés les
chiens ou les chiens sont il a enfin
avec qui sont arrivés les dingos ou voir
même son ne sont ils pas arrivé tout
seul en australie ça va c'est une
question à laquelle
pour laquelle l'arrêt la réponse va être
fortement influencée par la position
phylogénétique des dingos donc en
fonction de cil et dago sont des chiens
très bazzo comme ici ou bien des chiens
qui appartiennent à des membres des
races plus dérivés de chiens ça va pas
du tout être la même histoire même
archéologiques c'est là où je veux en
venir c'est même archéologiquement
parlant c'est plus du tout la même
histoire donc c'est super intéressant
comme d'habitude et on attend d'en
savoir plus en tout cas ce serait bien
qu'ils augmentent leur échantillonnage
parce que seulement un si petit
échantillonnage de comparaison ça
affaiblit quand même pas mal les les
conclusions voilà c'était paléo news je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]